Firstly,
I want to say thank you so much,
those an amazing talk and I was
wondering if you could elaborate.
What I noticed a lot,
I go here to UBC is that a lot of
students and young people,
they're often desensitized to,
for example,
the atrocities that communism or
ideologies that forged terrorism and
maybe it's some sort of Stockholm
syndrome that I'm seeing where it's like
people are just,
they're,
they're like trapped and they can't.
They feel in a way they can't do
anything about it and then they start to
like,
like communism or they start to see more
social or adopt socialist policy that in
the end we'll get them killed.
We'll get them hurt as long as you kind
of elaborate on what you think can be
done about that or even if something can
be done in that respect.
Well,
I think something can be done.
I mean I've been trying to educate
people about the horrors of the Nazi
regime in the Soviet regime in
particular.
I've concentrated mostly on those two
cars,
but that's good enough and trying to let
people know that it was through the
fault of people,
much like them,
that those systems are rows and,
and that there are steps you can take to
limit the probability that you would
participate in such a thing and that
those steps are associated with trying
to be truthful in your speech and
actions because the stability of those
systems depends on the willingness of
individuals to lie and,
and also on your willingness to take
responsibility for the malevolence in
your own heart.
That manifests itself in those social
movements.
And so that when I've done,
when I do my lectures,
when I do talks like this,
when I put them on Youtube,
what I'm trying to do is exactly that
because that was the best pathway
forward through such things that I could
think up over 20 years of thinking about
it.
Um,
you know,
one is so habituated to suffering that
they can read the Gulag archipelago,
which is actually quite hard to read
without having an effect them like your
psychopathic.
If that book doesn't affect you,
you know it should.
If you read it properly,
it affects you deeply and it's not the
only example of that kind of literature.
So the people who are habituated aren't.
They've just been shown low resolution
representations of things they don't
understand that looked vaguely bad.
You don't know a damn thing about them,
and our education system has done a
tremendously appalling job of educating
young people about the absolute
catastrophe of radical leftism.
Now it's not much better with regards to
say the actions of the Nazis,
although I would say on average people
are more aware of that,
but they don't.
But it's shallow,
shallow knowledge.
So you make the knowledge deep and deep
knowledge changes people and wakes them
up.
You know?
I mean,
the only reason that I ever got
convinced that they're that good and
evil,
we're real more real than anything else
wasn't because I learned that good was
real.
That's hard.
It's hard to learn that.
You have to find examples of
transcendent good.
You know,
they're rare,
evil.
All you have to do is look,
read history a bit and read it like it's
about you and there's no way that you
can do that without a transformation,
but people won't do it.
It's like you want to imagine yourself
as an Auschwitz guard.
That's a rough thing you see because you
have to figure out.
See Young said,
if you confronted the shadow,
which is the dark side of people,
the aggressive side,
the malevolent side,
that it.
It really reaches all the way down to
hell and Dante sort of was trying to put
forward the same thing when he wrote the
inferno,
right?
With the levels of evil,
Because it was a voyage through the
levels of evil,
right to the bottom.
He thought the bottom was betrayal.
It's pretty good.
The most.
The center of malevolence is betrayal.
I liked that because to be trained,
someone,
you have to get them to trust you,
and trust is a moral virtue,
right?
Especially if it's courageous trust,
because it it.
It puts you in alignment with other
people and allows you to move forward
into life and if you'd be trained that
you really,
it's like a knife in the.
It's like knife in the heart,
through the back,
especially if it's someone who loves,
loves you,
betrays you,
and especially if they betray you for
your virtues.
That's a really nice twist.
So I believe because I think that people
are capable of good,
that if they know enough about evil that
that will straighten them out.
So,
but who wants that?
You know,
this is one of the things I really like
about young.
He's often regarded as a new age thinker
that's wrong.
There's no new age thinker.
He knew that the,
the pathway to enlightenment was barred
by the necessity of a passage through
hell and that no one was going to do
that.
That's why there isn't a world full of
enlightened people.
You might say like it was just a matter
of doing nice things following your
bliss.
Let's say however you might put it.
Then why wouldn't everyone walk up the
stairway to heaven?
That isn't how it works.
That's not how it works at all.
I don't think you can be convinced of
the necessity for moral action until you
understand exactly how dark and terrible
things can get,
and then it's your fault that they're
getting that way.
Who wants to think that?
So you can think it though,
but not.
Not Without it burning you.